Hi, I'm Christopher Simone and I'm the scout master of Troop 71 in Plendome, New York.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me
And now the old scout master.
So two scouts were sharing a tent and one of them reached into his pack and got a
piece of chalk out and marked a big X in chalk on the bottom of the tent.
And the other scout looked at him and said: why did you do that?
And he said: well, this is such a great campsite,
This is just a perfect campsite.
We could see the lake from here.
There was a nice breeze blowing.
We're just perfectly situated.
So I wanted to make sure that I could. I marked it and remembered exactly where
this site was. so next time we go camping, you know, we can get this site.
And the other scout looked at him and said: he said that's never going to work.
We may get a different tent next time.
Oh, OK,
Hey, everybody, this is podcast number two hundred and twenty three.
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag over on Facebook.
Robert Owen got in touch with us and said: many thanks,
You have the blog.
I always thought I'd write. so I appreciate your assumption of that task.
Well, Robert, we live to serve.
What can I say?
And that comment came on the post on Facebook that announced our PDF package.
Now, if you haven't looked into this, I believe I mentioned it last week,
but I put together a downloadable zip file of all of the infographics
and some other useful PDF documents.
There's more than 40 of them there that you can get by going to scoutmastercgcom
And you'll see there's an announcement about that right at the top of the page
And you can go ahead and get that and use it to further cause the scouting
Wherever you are. there are some. the infographics cover things like
camping skills and knots and games
And there's some other helpful things in there for youth leader training
and just a whole bunch of stuff.
And Wes Fish wrote in after he got the PDF package and he said:
honestly, I first downloaded the free version, but once I got a look at it,
I went back and I paid for it
And, by the way, the PDF package is there for free.
It's absolutely there for free.
It can be distributed to all of you.
I also provided a way that you can provide a small payment-
It's $5- towards helping make it possible to create resources like that.
The point is is it's there for your scouts?
And Wes went on to say: you know, I've been burned once or twice
with this sort of thing online
And, Wes, I know exactly what you're talking about,
So I'm a little more careful of paying. first
Matter of fact, I shared the link to the page with our local district
on our Facebook page.
I don't know how you and others like you find the time
and energy to do these things.
Thanks for your efforts,
Wes. I'm glad that you found the things in the PDF package
useful and I appreciate your feedback on it.
Alex Gomez checked in with us this week from Guatemala City
in Guatemala.
Thanks, Alex.
Always good to hear from scouts from different parts of the
world.
Michelle checked in to say: love your site,
Great idea,
Thanks.
Well, thank you, Michelle.
Peter said I am a cub master in it,
Atlanta, Georgia.
My son just completed weeblos and is now a part of our troop.
Our troop is growing,
So I wanted to find out more about how a troop operates.
Your material is excellent.
Thanks for putting it together
Well. thank you, Peter,
And thanks for volunteering for scouting.
Keep in touch with us
If you have questions or you need help with anything,
we'll make sure that you get it.
Chris touched base with us to say, as we say in my troop,
to commend someone on a good deed.
As President Roosevelt said, the first president was
Teddy bully.
I find your pearls of wisdom and valuable as a scout master.
often publish them on our website and our Facebook page.
Thanks, Chris.
Go ahead and publish away,
Share the links to our articles and anything else that gets
created.
All as we ask is that you let people know where it came
from,
That's all,
But as long as it's going out there to help scouts,
that's that's what really counts.
Michael is the scout master of troop one thing
Four in Santa Rosa, California, and he wrote in about
something we talked about on a recent podcast. after
hearing about the scout master that does all the grocery
shopping for his patrols,
He had the right idea, but the wrong approach.
The best way to look at this is to compare it to two
pieces of gear.
We should be a safety net,
But not a safety harness.
The difference is that the harness keeps you from
falling,
Whereas the net let you go.
The difference is that the harness keeps you from
falling, whereas the net let you fall but keeps you
from getting hurt when you do.
As an example for last week's backpacking outing,
I packed along an extra freeze dried meal and some
extra oatmeal.
That way, if a scout somehow forgot his food and if
none of the other scouts had any to spare, he
wouldn't go hungry.
Now, would I sleep better if I just purchased all
the meals for the scouts and distributed them
to them?
Well, sure I would,
But the boys wouldn't learn how to double check
their packs and they wouldn't learn how to be
themselves.
Michael, that's a great picture:
The idea of a safety net rather than a safety
harness
And, as you said, the safety harness that prevents
you from falling, but the net let you fall and
keeps you from getting hurt when you do.
I love the picture and thanks for being in
touch. Mike.
Bobby said thanks for a great site.
I'm working on my wood badge project and
collecting resources on retaining scouts.
I saw one of your articles on it and I'm
going to include it in my project.
We're working on that wood badge ticket and
I'm glad I could be of help
On the blog this past week most recently,
let's see, we had a couple of features from
Baden Powell's blog.
If you haven't seen that I'm posting short
articles that were written by Baden Powell
during his lifetime on every Sunday,
So you might want to check that out.
I posted a great article by Enoch Heisey
on Green Bar Life this week-
What a patrol leader does when things go
wrong,
Because you know things are going to go
wrong so you better know what to do right.
But Enoch's got some great advice for
patrol leaders and youth leaders there.
We posted another infographic
about outdoor clothing.
You know I find it a little surprising that
parents don't pay that close of attention
sometimes to what their scouts are going
to wear in the outdoors.
The clothing infographic is just
basics, just an introduction to
some of the issues that you might want to
think about.
So make sure to check that out and check out
our gear guide too.
It covers all kinds of camping gear and
there's a lot of information in there that
will be useful when you go to choose
camping gear for your scout.
We had a Scoutmasters minute
that we published this week
talking about a couple of big birds-
eagles and peacocks.
If you haven't seen that, go to
scoutmasterscgcom and check it out.
And then last week's podcast. we had
our interview with Darnell Daly.
James Chaplin wrote in and said:
Another fantastic podcast,
Thanks.
I had the privilege of meeting Darnell
when I took my troop to his council's
camp in Hawk Mountain.
He made a personal effort to talk to
each and every adult leader that week
and as many scouts as time permitted.
He was a very open and humble person.
I really appreciated the interview,
especially the quotes no man matures past
age 12.
And your discussion of how having a
long tenure in scouting can cut both
ways.
I'm hitting my mid-fifties and I'm
watching this happen
amongst my peers in scouting as I
muddle forward into different district
events.
Thanks so much for being in touch,
James.
I always appreciate hearing from you.
Now I talked to you about the PDF
package, but I want to make sure to let
you know that, as you heard at the
top of the podcast, we enjoy the
sponsorship of scoutmasterscgcom
backers.
The funds that backers provide go to
and lay the cost of producing and
publishing all the content that we
make available on scoutmasterscgcom.
It's pretty easy to become a backer.
I offer different premiums for
you choose, and within this past week
I want to take the time to thank Timothy
Ferrarati and Adam Cox for becoming
backers.
Thank you very much, fellas.
I really do appreciate it, and it keeps
us on the air, keeps us online.
Well, this Monday happens to be Memorial
Day, and I hope that you're all
celebrating Memorial Day and remembering
our veterans,
So this podcast may be a little bit
briefer than usual.
I have an interview that courted
this past week that I think you're
going to find particularly inspiring.
As you'll hear, it all started with an
email that I received from one of my
listeners, and I really felt the point
behind what he had to say was something
that you would appreciate hearing, and
what you're going to hear is a very
simple story.
It's not a story that you would end
up reading in boys life or
scouting magazine.
It's not one that you would hear on
the news, but the really important
things that happen for us in
scouting and happen for our scouts.
our stories just like the one you're
talking about or anything like that,
but incredibly significant and
important in the lives of a
scout and his patrol and
his troop
And you know what-
Important in the lives of
Scouters too.
I hope you enjoy the interview, so
let's get started,
Shall we?
I had a really interesting
email a couple of weeks ago from
a scoutmaster up in Corning,
New York.
I asked him if he would take a
little time to talk with me on the
podcast, because I think it's
something that everybody would
enjoy hearing.
And so, from Corning, New York,
Scoutmaster Troop 61,, Bob
Case is on the phone with me.
How are you doing, Bob?
I'm good, Clark.
How are you doing?
Well, you know we're doing the
best that we can.
You guys headed off recently to
the 52nd annual
West Point Camperry.
So did you take a big crowd with
you?
We ended up taking 15 boys and
five adults.
Two of the boys that we took were
actually from one of our sister
troops in our area, from
Troop 2..
It's a pretty big crowd that
shows up there, isn't it?
Well, I tell you, Clark, this
point Camperry, the day I've
ever had, there was a total of
7,600 Scouts and
Scouts including the Cadets,
as this thing was huge-
The biggest one that I've ever
had in 52 years-
And so you went up there on a
Friday.
Yes,
You have to backpack in.
We applied to be a
Lightfighter troop, which
means that everything we needed
for the three days needed to
be in.
So we had everything loaded on
our backs and it was probably
the most grueling hike we've
ever been on,
Headed to the summit of Bull
Hills, which is the summit peak
there at West Point,
And we got a special commemorative
pin for climbing to the top of
Bull Hill.
You get into your site and
you get set up on Friday night
and it's getting around dinner
time because your son, Joe,
is actually your senior patrol
leader.
Okay,
And what happened next?
I want to get Joe's
end of that story.
Hello,
Hey, Joe,
I got your dad to tell us
a little bit about getting to
the West Point Campery.
You guys hiked in-
Yeah,
He said it, just about killed him.
How did it do for you?
It was all right.
The trailhead was
really muddy and there was a lot
of rocks, but overall it was a
really beautiful hike.
You get up to your site there
and you get set up.
How long have you been your troop
senior patrol leader?
I'm actually finishing out my
term now and I've been the senior
patrol leader for one doubting
year, so to speak.
So you started back last fall
or last spring.
So I would have started last
spring and then I've been the
SPL until now.
So let me ask you about being
the senior patrol leader just a
little bit.
We're going to get back to the
story here in a second.
So you become the senior
patrol leader. at the beginning
Not really,
I don't think any of us really
does.
I was excited about it because
I'd gone from being just a
senior patrol leader and then
thrown right into the senior
patrol leader position, kind of
without a choice, because nobody
wanted to be the SPL and quite
obviously, without an SPL there's
no troop.
So I kind of took the bull by
the horns and went at it.
Let's go back to Friday night
and then we'll get back to the
story.
What exactly was going on there?
Honestly, from my perspective,
chaos.
I instructed the boys to kind
of set it up one way, but then
they kind of started doing
something completely different.
It was starting to get a little
out of hand, I guess you could
say.
There was other boys who were
struggling to get their tent set
up, and then there was me who
hadn't even gotten to start
the camp.
This sounds like a pretty typical
camp out to me.
Yes, it was.
We had to find them cooking
groups, so to speak.
One boy packed in the stove,
another one packed in the fuel
and the third one packed in the pot.
What ended up happening was
there were certain individuals who
had been asking the adults
for their water instead of making
their own.
The way I see it is, we asked you
to carry that stuff in so that
you can take your meals and
carry your own.
It's not fair to the adults, who
packed that stuff in and have
to wait to boil more water
because you're taking mirrors.
I kind of got a little frustrated
with it, but I just kind of let it go.
You had a discussion with the
scout master about this.
What did you tell them?
It's unfair to the adults because
they have to wait longer to get
their hot water.
You were really invested in having
the patrols take care of this,
right?
Yeah,
The patrols are supposed to carry
their own.
Now this seems like kind of.
I mean, I'm calling you up and
I'm asking you to talk about this
story and everything, but you
stood up for what was supposed
to happen and you went to the
adults and you kind of told
them: why are you giving these
guys this water?
That takes some guts.
It did take a little bit of
pulling up, so to speak, to be
able to do that. because they
are the adults,
You need to take the reins
that we are doing something
that you don't really like or
you would like us to change.
talk to us about it and we'll
see what we can do.
It's different from the home
environment, where the adults
are the elders, so to speak,
and you go to them and you
don't really tell them what
to do, to scouting, where you
get to go to the adults and
ask them to do those things.
How did that go over with the
scout master?
For the most part it went over
pretty well.
Didn't get angry with you?
Not really. no,
At first he was kind of
struggling to see it from my
point of view, but then, after
a little bit more of an
explanation and speaking
about it more, we did
see eye to eye and we did
realize that it was time to
make the change.
How did the rest of Camp
Areco
Actually? Camp Areco was
amazing.
When do you hand over
being a senior patrol leader?
I'll actually hand it over
next Wednesday at our
Court of Honor.
You're going to miss it. you
think
Yes and no.
I think I'll miss
leading the boys to an extent
and always knowing what's
going on and knowing the
plan, but at the same time
I think it'll be a release
to finally not have to bear
that stress.
Yeah, I mean, it's a big job,
isn't it?
It is a big job.
It's a little stressful at
times as well.
If you could tell every other
senior patrol leader or
patrol leader, any scout
who has a position of
responsibility in their troop,
about your experience,
you get to tell them
something encouraging or
something they may not
understand about the
experience.
What would you tell them?
I would tell them to
always ask the boys what
they would want to improve on,
because, as a leader of
boys, I always try to
make the program as
enjoyable as possible- and
just to be able to
not only ask the boys what
they want, but to ask them
what they didn't like, and
to be able to take that
constructive criticism and,
instead of taking it to heart,
to run with it and
take the constructive
criticism and try it and
see how it works, because
the worst that's going to
happen is it's not going to
work well and you're just
going to try something
different.
Yeah, right, I mean, give this
a try. if it doesn't work
well, we'll try another one.
so, yeah, that's a good
attitude.
I like that.
Maybe you know this
and maybe you don't, but
adults sometimes we get a
little frustrated with you
guys.
Yeah, I know that
None of this is supposed
to be easy. none of this is
a walk in the park. it's
supposed to be challenging.
from the perspective of
being a senior patrol leader,
what do you tell these
other adults? how do you
encourage them to work
with their youth leadership?
I would definitely encourage
them to remember to listen,
because as teenagers we
don't have as much
experience as they do
communicating how we feel.
so we tend to say how we
feel in a kind of blunt
way because we haven't quite
learned fully how to express it
in a different way. so don't
exactly take it as blunt
and rude as it may sound,
because I know from my personal
experience when I first started
this term I didn't. I had
struggled expressing how I felt
about something, so quite
oftentimes I would come off
as rude and almost bashful
just because I had struggled
to expressing myself
differently.
Did you find that the
adults in your troop
actually were able to listen
to you?
It was a little bit of give
and take because I talked to
them about it, but we had
kind of came to the compromise
of: I'll remember to work on
my social skills. if you
remember that I don't mean
to be rude and bashful
when I speak.
That is a really excellent
advice job:
Taking the time to listen,
understanding that you're
still working on things that
they have been pretty good
at for maybe a few years,
and being patient.
I definitely agree. that's
what I'm still working on
personally is patient.
And how old are you now?
I'm 15..
I got to tell you
you communicate very well.
I was really fascinated
with the story that your dad
told me about this particular
incident, because a lot of
times these really really
important things in scouting
that adults need to know
kind of boil down to very
simple stories.
Your advice to adults is
really really great, and
I'm sure you're going to
miss being senior patrol
leader. what's your next
leadership position? do you
think
The historian?
I think it'd be kind of fun
to start taking pictures
and creating slide shows
and things of that type
for the troop.
I wish I had more time
to do that myself.
Well, Joe, I appreciate you
taking the time to speak
with me.
Good on you for your job
as senior patrol leader
and I'm sure you're going
to have a lot more fun.
You still got a few years
left to have fun in scouts.
You're going to be an
Eagle Scout, do you figure?
Yeah, I'm life right now
and I'm going to be doing
my Eagle project over the
summer, so I should have
it quite soon.
Excellent,
Well, congratulations my friend.
Is your dad still there
or I can talk to him?
Yeah, he's still here.
Thanks, Joe.
Yeah, you're welcome.
All right, here he is.
Hi, Clark,
You got to be smiling
right now.
Absolutely,
From year to year,
Joe didn't seem to think
the hike was quite so
difficult as you did.
Well, you know, when we're
40 years old, things look
a little bit different than
they do to a 15 year old.
You figure, huh,
Yeah,
What did you get out
of that experience?
Was there a sudden
revelation or was it something
you've been looking for
for a long time, that you
finally saw?
If you had the ear of other
scout leaders, which you do
actually right now, what would
you tell them about this
experience that was
particularly meaningful, was
particularly informative to you?
Well, the one thing that
we've been working on for
several years is the
patrol method and to get
the patrol method to work,
And the one thing that I
always told myself and my son
and the other
assistant scout masters
and the adults of the troop
is: be patient,
It will happen.
And camp out after camp out.
there was things that weren't
getting done and you know,
there was those little failures,
but all those little failures
they fixed them.
And when we got to West Point,
and that time at dinner time,
when all those instances
were just like you know what
you guys are, the kids,
we're the adults, we can wait.
And when we got the
tough love, so to speak, of
you know, this is your patrol,
you need to take care of your patrol.
it was one of those awe
inspiring moments.
And I look at my assistant
scout master, who was the
previous scout master,
and we just look each other and
smile
And we knew right then
that the troop had just
changed,
Changed for the better, and
it changed for everything
that we were looking for.
and we finally come
and the patrol leader started
taking charge
and the patrol members
were doing what they were
supposed to do.
So the one thing I can say is:
don't give up.
Trust the program.
You know, the one thing that
Boy Scouts has taught me
and taught a lot of my
friends that I work with is
that it lets these boys
do things that they don't
get to do in school,
and they get to learn how
to lead,
They get to take care of
themselves and learn
what responsibility is,
And they finally did that,
And it's just amazing.
So, having faith in the
program, it doesn't look like
anything until it looks like
something
Right,
Which can take a while.
It sure can.
And now you're going to have
a new senior patrol leader.
what next Wednesday?
Is that what Joe said?
Yes,
They had their elections last
night.
We have a new senior patrol
leader,
Four new patrol leaders,
And they were ones that
were part of the trip to
West Point
And it has been around
And they're ready.
They're fighting it a bit
to start playing it,
But in some ways it's all
going to start over again too.
Yes, it is.
Yes,
I've had it pretty easy,
Clark,
I tell you, having Joe
being my senior patrol leader
for my first time,
being a Scout Master,
it helped out a lot
to have him around,
And you may think that
he'll just be able to
go back to being just a
Scout, but I have a feeling
that he'll always be a leader
to the other boys
And he has already
got everything set for him
to start helping out
the next senior patrol leader,
And I think he's excited.
Excellent,
Excellent.
Well, it's a great story
and I appreciate you taking
the time to share it with us.
I'm sure people will find it
inspiring.
Great
Well, thanks again, Bob.
Thank you.
Thank you for everything.
It's my pleasure,
Especially when I hear
stories like this.
Thanks for allowing Joe
to speak with me.
I really do appreciate it.
Oh, you're welcome.
No problem,
Okie doke thanks.
Thank you, Clark.
Right,
Bye-bye.
Hey. thanks for listening
to this 223rd edition
of the Scout Master podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
Read the blog at ScoutMasterCGcom
While you're there.
make sure you subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
by email.
You can get the Scout Master
CG app on Google Play
or at the iTunes App Store.
That way, you can keep up
with all of the resources
that we create.
You can have them right there
on your mobile device.
You can experience the wonders
of ScoutMasterCGcom
as they are
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Join 5,400 folks
who like Scout Master blog
on Facebook.
Tweet along with a chorus
of 1,000-plus tweeters on Twitter
and pin the Pultritudinous pictures
proffered publicly
with 1,500 other prolific pinners
on Pinterest.
You can watch us over
at Scout Master CG on YouTube
and join the 400-odd folks
who form the exclusive
Scout Master CG circle on Google+.
Now, naturally,
if you really can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you bitter,
if you've no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube
and when it comes to Google+
you're a minus. don't worry, monkey,
You can zoom into the late 90s
and fire off an email.
Yep, you can get in touch with me
at Clark at ScoutMasterCGcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutMasterCGcom.
The Scout Master blog
and the Scout Master podcast
are not official publications of anybody-
No, not the Boy Scouts of America-
and they're not endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization
for that matter.
I'm pretty sure
they have more important things
to do with their time.
Hey, it's just me.
I've got a microphone
and a way to get online
and you just happen to be listening
and I'm just happened to try
to be lending a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun,
before we go,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.
Thank you.